what I hear they have a nickname for you
in Korea I love this nickname did you
love it uh it it was a is it the
nation's boyfriend yeah I was like do I
say this myself nation's it's I think
it's is the n the nation's boyfriend
yeah I was called the nation's boyfriend
that's just like everyone's boyfriend
I'm
just the nation's boyfriend what does
this mean have you asked I was told well
so pretty much in Korea there's a phrase
called yeah that means one Eric Nom per
household so it's like it's it's like
actually kind of in like like the
dictionaries and like if you search it
it's like a thing you're like Beyonce
with bootylicious you just like made a
word like that's incredible but here's
the thing I didn't make it I don't know
who made it but it was made and then all
of a sudden I was on this uh this fun
reality show it was you know reality
where I'm fake married for like nine
months and through that and through
being on all these I know I know I know
how did you like being married how did
you like being married it was great does
it stick for
everyone well mine was like n months you
know again it was it was yeah in reality
also true um but it was fun but it was
through doing a lot of shows and I was
on any sort of TV show radio show
anything everywhere and I think people
just really saw me everywhere and I
think people liked me in general and so
I got very likable thank you yes you are
very like
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home